believe aljo said that in a perfect
world to defend it like once or twice
and then he'll go up give him Robbie's
time and I'll tell you right now I do
believe this dude I'm not sure on
vulcanowski he's one of my short bold
stocky hero I like him my thing is I
feel if aljo had that back and I'm and
listen it's just like Al Joe with his
arms their wiry I believe he'll if he
doesn't get the neck he'll break the jaw
I believe he gets that back he's
finishing how about that I agree fully
with your mat you know doing Jujitsu
Brendan a smaller Winery guy on your
back get worse than the big Meathead
even technique and skill you know I
would say algae when it comes to
straight Brazilian Jiu Jitsu is way more
verse than that than machachev is so if
algebra were to get volkanovsi's back
that's a long night in the office that's
a winnable fight